than a dozen states faced air quality
alerts with the haze obscuring the
Statue of Liberty as well as downtown
Philadelphia and historic landmarks in
the nation's capital in New York mayor
Eric Adams said the air quality was at
its worst since the 1960s on Broadway
the conditions prompted two musicals to
cancel their shows the New York Liberty
postponed its WNBA game and the Yankees
rescheduled their matchup with the
Chicago White Sox it all comes after an
unusually early and intense start to
Canada's Wildfire season more than 400
wildfires are burning across the country
over half of them still out of control
nearly 9.4 million Acres have burnt in
2023 that's roughly 15 times the average
according to Canada's minister of
emergency preparedness this is perhaps
the worst year that we have experienced
with wildfires as long as we've been
keeping records